my children are very well versed
in everything marvel they know the whole
universe so
juan division has been uh
they love it and what's a little
frustrating for me is i don't know the
marvel world as well as they do
so they have stopped me every 10 minutes
they want to stop and talk about
some clue that they just saw that has
great meaning
um and they they absolutely love it they
explained to me and i didn't know this
that your character your your
involvement with marvel
as vision started with you being the
voice of jarvis
and i knew that jarvis was the voice of
tony stark's computer and the iron man
films and i thought
they explained to me the whole evolution
of how
jarvis becomes vision and i thought
thank you children
i appreciate that what i didn't know was
how
you got that part in the first place how
did you get the part
of jarvis uh yeah it was i made a
movie years ago called wimbledon and in
wimbledon john
favreau played my agent rather
brilliantly and then
john favreau then sort of became a big
director
and he he called me up and he said paul
paul
and i said yes john how are you and he
said i'm really well i went what can i
do for you and he said
well i'm making this movie and there's
that it's iron man so they're you know
there's tony stark
and he has this suit and i need this
disembodied voice
of a sort of a
you know a personality less uh
you know computer voice somebody with
just like no
character at all and i thought of you
[Laughter]
immediately
well john since you've pitched it so
nicely
um yeah i'm in and and that was how it
all began
well it's uh first of all i i you know
i i do disagree with him i think you've
got loads of personality
uh but um it worked out because you you
were jarvis
then uh jarvis becomes the vision
role and i'm thinking and now vision is
this very central part of this huge
franchise
and has led to one division so it's
beautiful beautiful the way it all laid
out for you
but what i'm here what i'm curious about
is marvel they put so much thought
so much thought into everything and i
know that when they're creating a new
character
or adapting a character from the comics
to film
they put an immense amount of thought
into what the character should look like
and there's this legend that they go
through hundreds of different
prototypes and looks before they settle
on one did that happen with vision
yes yeah there was a lot of work
done on that and just whedon was
um was uh manning the ship
at that point and he was you know
because
right at the beginning he was wondering
like vision's going to be
born we're going to see him uh born
and as i mean ostensibly naked
um he has to have a penis
right i mean because he's he's naked and
he's been born and
everybody there lost esposito kevin
fight
everybody was like i'm not sure that's
such a great idea for vision to have
you know for us for him to sort of rise
up out of the
crypt as it were with a with a you know
a penis and he said i need i
i need i need him to i need to see his
penis
so and this is a true story so there was
so artists were sent away to sort of
do all of these renderings of vision
being born
with with a with the penis and
they they they put them all up on this
huge wall of marvel studios
and they invited um they invited just in
and just stood
in front of this huge wall and he went
never have i been more sure that i don't
need to see
visioning with a penis
yeah because you don't want to see that
yeah yeah
when we were launching my show back in
93 there was a lot of discussion should
conan have a penis or not
and what did you decide we without uh oh
you were more than yeah it just um and
it
that seems to be better yeah who needs
it
you know um i'm who ever got me into the
trial
it's just exactly uh i'll make sure i
get the word out that the finale of one
division streams on disney plus
tomorrow and uh everyone's watching it
it is it's just been it must be fun for
you that it
you couldn't have imagined that it would
hit like this
absolutely not we we were not supposed
we you know we were supposed to come out
second and
we were all we always kind of thought we
were going to be the kooky
cousin kind of you know and see if he
embraced like this has just been amazing
to disseminate it
um week after week has also
uh been great and um i've got a lot of
mixed emotions about that
finishing today like it's yeah it's
gonna be out
and we've crashed the disney um the
disney plus platform twice
that's fantastic yes that's fantastic
whenever you can break
anything that disney has made
i can't believe it like so many people
wanted to watch it and i was like wow
and it was uh yeah so tonight everybody
tune in
and tune in and let's yes let's destroy
uh let's destroy a streaming service
tonight let's do it together